it was an article Angela
the final phase of our well
salamualikum' entered a very casual
boxing system the offense focus has been
well welcome to video shala
on this video we're going to discuss an
evil force on what salsa and all the
suffers from this even myself whoever it
may be the biggest scholar the biggest
dive the companions everybody suffers
from this now we need to know how to
deal with this because it is a problem
which can psychologically affect you and
if it's a politically affect you can
have a physical effect on your whole
body and the whole way of thinking and
it can put you into depression
and that's why this is something I
thought is very very important for us to
tackle so our core five steps we will
describe said we're going to acknowledge
and diagnose the problem where it's
coming from
and share some information from the
comparative component go through this
how the process of them and our sponsor
law gives the draw for this excited
now there's a variety of issues like for
example you will get individuals who
will have doubts in a religion for
example the first of a solemn said the
Shaitaan will come and say to you who
created the better than the earth that
you say Allah you click to the Sun you
say Allah who created the start and say
Allah that he will continue instead say
well then who created Allah so this is
actually Tom works he has a step-by-step
thing to lead you to destruction now
this question we answer it and our daily
basis to level two and our it's a whole
new topic you can watch our videos
however this is one kind of what's
what's up an evil force about Shaitaan
gives you the other can be regarding
your prey are useful out you're a bada
so for example when you're praying to
serve all you might get yourself you
know did that pray did I why except it
was my intention right this is this is a
common phenomena that a lot of people
hopefully something will do will do and
then the toilet - outsourcing an arm is
that part of the elbow or missed this
much I miss thing like this so they go
into this hope in this kind of thinking
and the more you feed it the more it
gets worse then you get that now you get
the shame I'll come and try to give you
what sort up with fear ah you know what
if this person dies or look what's
happening similar or look what's
happened in this country and what's
happened to the Muslims they start if I
like this existed why all these evil
things happen
or for example scare you with death so
variety of stuff yeah what was the
content different shapes and different
forms it might be with your risk for
example your provision when you give in
charity hey don't give in charity you
know etc etc so this is an is more that
I can think of maybe different people
goes in different ways we now combine no
status a okay look this are this is a
symptoms this is a symptoms of it now
this is the first part the second part
is
who is this coming from now this is
really simple some of you guys might
think obviously you know can it be fun
for Shaitaan but know sometimes Shaitaan
tricks your fingers from Allah you know
lesson in your warning you know so you
need to ask yourself a question can this
be from Allah these evil thoughts and
negative thoughts and what's worse are
can this be from Allah now copy from
Allah can this be from the Angels nope
why would it be strange why would
English put such things in your head
obviously it's from the Shaitaan yeah so
we need to acknowledge through what are
the center's and who is the culprit the
culprit the Shaitaan Shaitaan took an
oath by a large name that he would miss
sky the human kindness son of Adam so
the Shaitaan that I will come from the
front and back left left and right so
he's an opened in his declared war with
you and me so we need to acknowledge
that and know our enemy yes and nobody
comes with
now I love you when they go for this
what's awesome depression whatever it
may be sometimes we go into this
mentality of thinking you know what it's
just me you know I'm I'm just going
through this you know but when you do
some research obviously I lost
automation in Hanzo when the processor
no certainly sometimes distressed with
certain methods and also other would
comfort him and say look but previous
prophets went through this don't make it
don't let it get you this is regarding a
different issue what we're trying to say
is the Companions the best of mankind to
walk the earth went through this now for
example let me show some narrations
review guys it is narrated by a Harada
may Allah be pleased with him some of
the components of The Messenger of Allah
peace in this world be upon him came to
the prophet and said to him we find in
our self first our terrible to speak off
he said are you really from something
are you really suffering for that they
said yes he said that is the clear sign
of faith now this is the hope for us
because it showed the folks Allah what
Allah is saying this is a clear sign of
faith you know now another thing I want
to share with you guys it was narrated
from even a pause may Allah be pleased
with him pleased with them both well
that a man came to the prophet peace of
allah be upon him I said I think forced
to myself which I would rather be burnt
to a cinder there speak of him and in
moderation the Prophet another companion
said I'll rather fall from the sky then
had these thoughts about allah his
messenger the prophet peace upon him
said praise be to Allah who has released
who has reduced all his shaytan's close
to a meal response now what this means
is that the prophet of Allah is giving
glad tidings for the one who's suffering
from the commit severe but also from
what source about the oh maybe that's a
severe one yeah that glad tidings to you
that the fact that you may be your
individual who prays does the first
surah gives in charity helps individuals
tells his brothers and sisters in need
abstain from major sins do some more
acts so for you is that glad time with
the chorus like look this close the
doors to sin and you're practicing your
religion and Shaitaan is looking at
thinking man attack describes inner or
the system I can't get into the river I
can't
into steel account going to do this or
cheat or dadada and his mirrors only
think that he's got net and the
phosphorus I'm saying glad tidings to
you is that the father is at the Shaytan
has got the worst loss helis he said the
only thing that can do is what was that
so he shows us the best of mankind
Winfrey so you're not alone in
technology now we know that we all
suffer from it the companion suffer from
it
so now it's about how do we deal with it
what did Allah and His Messenger give us
in ways of dealing with this now the
scholars say there is two things that
you need to do not brothers and sisters
anytime you get this evil force in yet
you need to make it to habit for
yourself and this is a hundred life form
of liquor for you is wrong with each
other you get rewarded every single time
when you are stuck here phrase number
I'm sorry oh and the shame tongue comes
on whispers yeah and said ah Harley
you're doing this for fame this is what
you're doing it for you know if it
wasn't for that you wouldn't do it I
mean you're doing it for that what is
the first thing that we are ordered to
do by the fo'c'sle solemn is we say I
will be laughing in a shaped army regime
and we turn to our left side and then we
spit three times and this doesn't mean
it will spit yeah we do yes yeah gently
okay
don't be spitting we're like big phlegm
you know and you're gonna end up spin on
your wife so it should only last or
wherever you have mobilization Shaitaan
you know calm down or disable a sister
obviously is the same cure for you guys
you say that
so then anytime this happens wherever
you are even if things mean means 100
times a day you do this 100 times a day
you say I will be landing in a shame
time meta-gene seek refuge in allah this
is the first thing yeah so what you're
doing is now you're fighting back the
second thing is any of those force do
not entertain it don't treat it like a
flower where you give water and it grows
and grows and grows and goes to a big
tree where you have a problem now so
what you do is you totally cut it ignore
it any kind of evil force that for
example this person is going to die any
families
how would we learn the shaitaan virgin
ignore ignore
same procedure these are the two things
that you need to do and inshallah you
would get rid of that
now another thing the processor I did
and is narrated by Aisha may Allah have
mercy on us that she narrated whenever I
was apostle
please the opponent went to bed every
night he used to cut his hands together
yeah conceivable and blow over after
reciting sort of solar class sort of
panic and swollen ass and then rub his
hand over whatever part of his body he
was able to rub starting with his head
face and front of his body he used to do
that three times narrated by Sahih
al-bukhari books book of virtues now
what that means Bhavan sisters is three
hands together you recite surat class
yeah sort of phallic ensued on us once
you have done that yeah and it does have
to be if I'm a secular heavy out loud
once you've done that using you broke
through three times and you wipe over
your face yeah arms your body all the
way down to your feet the first person
would do that before going to bed every
night and it will protect you from any
kind of any kind of evilness yeah
because if we look at soda as glass I
mean look up sort of salad and soda Nass
when you'll see what the DeWyze about
this lesson is really for ourselves
together yet I would be learning the
Machine time energy in this meal I
demanded I him say I seek refuge in the
lord of daybreak from the evil of that
which he created and from the evil of
darkness when it settles and from the
evil of the blowers in knots yeah
magicians you invoke the magic and from
the evil of the of an envier when he
envies a lot of us sadly when we're out
and about we always show off our car our
partners our clothes our house our days
and dad let's sleep on that Envy so it's
about asking protection from that now
going to the next surah surah Naas and
this one says say I seek refuge in The
Lord of mankind the sovereign of mankind
the god of mankind
from the evil of the retreating
Whisperer yes who whispers evil into the
breasts of mankind yes it was over a
Shaitaan you know and from the from
among the jinn and mankind yes
so you asked in protection from these
evil things yes and obviously so the
class is saying he is Allah who is one
Allah the eternal refuge
he neither begets nor is He begotten nor
is any thing equivalent term anything
liking yes so once you read his father
and sisters inshallah with a permission
of us wanna tell you be protected and
the reminders I want to give the
government sister is remember I'm not as
much as you can wherever you are for
example if you're out and about getting
a haircut on the bus walking jogging
training whatever it may be is it really
hard to say I'm doing nothing to shy up
say inside you I don't know you know I
start for a lot of stuff for a lot the
prophet sallallaahu Lewis ll words
within the region that says he would art
you would do stuff far more than 70
kinda be yeah so you should do the same
stuff for about hundred allah allah
akbar subhan allah these are things that
are light on the tongue but heavy on the
scale could be some their judgment
bonuses hobbies as a benefited may Allah
bless every single one of you guys
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi well
better care to do share through your
friends and family who are suffering
from what wasa an evil force
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo hey give
me one I'm sorry
subscribe oh shoot